that's so dumb the movie that set the
bar for pretty much all cg in today's
modern era
we've gotta re-render this we have two
weeks
so here here's the genius
there's a bunch of other react videos
online with various professionals in
their field talking about cool works of
whatever it is that they do and we
wanted to try doing that ourselves here
so this is the second video we've made
we had an amazing response to the first
video thank you to all of you who
subscribed to the channel if you think
of a video you want us to react to
visual effects you want us to break down
please leave a comment all right what's
the first video
harry is still alive
case closed i do really like the fur
they made that fur look really good oh
dude it looks warm and soft yeah look at
my cat it's like a little cat when we
were analyzing sonic i mentioned how the
green of his eyes was more saturated
than the green in the background sure
like if sonic was actually there and you
actually filmed him with a camera your
camera wouldn't suddenly be able to
arbitrarily capture more saturation on
him than the other stuff that's green in
the scene it needs to obey the rules of
your camera in this scene
no colors are more saturated than the
other like the green on the bubble sores
back is the exact same green saturation
as the background the eyes are pushing
it a little bit but even then not that
much
my first reaction to seeing a lot of
these shots is that they they added fur
to a lot of pokemon that and through the
cartoons you can't really do fur i never
really considered a lot of these pokemon
to even have fur i think like the
artists had to sit there and think like
okay which direction do the hairs go
like you're here's the direction there's
like there's an evolutionary direction
there's there's hair brushes like
digital cg hair brushes that you can
actually shape the hair with and then it
kind of stays there and then it kind of
reacts to the motion what clumps up it's
like in tufts yeah you know it's not
just like all hairs individually spaced
apart from each other like your hair is
kind of clump up and where do you see
that uh armpits yeah like right in there
yeah there's like tonality differences
to the hair but to be fair hair is
something that we've been able to do for
over 15 years pretty well monsters inc
was like the first time i've ever seen
zinc was the first time hair was
actually a thing but you can see how how
much fewer hairs there are here yeah
well like i'm specifically looking at
his left shoulder there you can see
individual hairs yeah and if you're to
do that today there'd be probably 10 to
100 times more hairs per square inch you
might remember in the last video we
talked about ambient occlusion hair has
a lot of ambient occlusion underneath
your hair near the roots mostly hair bow
is locking a lot of the light and that's
how you get kind you can kind of see the
layers of hair on top of themselves
subsurface scattering on on his face
look at the dodgeball shoulders dude
it is a dodge ball oh my god this
straight up has dodgeball's shoulders
hair is not 100 opaque it's actually
slightly translucent and so the fringes
of the hair on pikachu's tail they're
catching the light in front of pikachu
and that's getting a little edge kind of
looks like a stroke around the so those
are the little tips of the hair catching
light but then the light actually enters
the hair and then passes through it
after being diffused a little bit now
that's something that monsters inc was
missing and that's what makes fur look
very realistic in these scenes they did
a really good job of setting up the
lighting to work really well with these
cg characters it looks like a one or two
point kind of light setup you have the
light in the far back blasting it right
and that's causing the shadow down here
in the foreground and then you have like
an overhead kind of fill for me some
scenes are easier to light in cg if it's
like a one point light yeah it just
looks better very specific directional
lighting helps a lot for
creating cg scenes
so here here's the genius of this scene
one of the things that makes stuff look
real is something called radiosity or
global illumination goes by a lot of
different names so basically it's the
way light bounces i'm showing the
flashlight on my hand
and it's lighting up the side of his
face in cg to get that you have to
simulate a ray coming out of the light
hitting a surface and scattering and
bouncing off but you have to do it many
many many many times to get all the
scatters and get your sampling of the
environment and that's a lot of math
they can't do bounce lighting back then
there's no option to do bounce lighting
so what do they do they set their scene
at night with a single source of light
and that's it notice how the dark parts
in the scene where the headlights aren't
hitting the t-rex it's just pitch black
so you don't have to worry about bounce
light great problem one solved good job
everybody your geniuses number two by
making it rain they can have specular
lighting all over the t-rex make it feel
like it's reflective but all they have
to reflect is a white spot notice you
can see the specular on his legs on his
toes on the side of his
thigh
he's just shiny as a whole he's just
shiny but all you're trying all you're
showing for reflection is basically a
blob of white pretty much here onwards
all of this right here is a real t-rex
they have the perfect reference that's
an animatronic t-rex head if that they
have actual footage of that that they
can match the cg one too if they didn't
have that they'd be like how dark do we
make it how reflective do we make it so
good it's so scary
jeff goldblum you madman you hero also i
think this is the first shot where the
camera's actually moving through 3d
space
that was a very challenging shot right
there this shot in particular
this was the hardest shot in the whole
movie i talked about this in my ted talk
but there's a single frame oh what are
we gonna see so the the t-rex obviously
grabs the the velociraptor but for one
single frame that is in the final movie
i'm waiting for this i'm on the edge of
my seat
[Laughter]
for one frame the velociraptor is
completely missing i think what happened
is that the the 3d models the actual
files they sent to the cache to be
rendered for whatever reason on that one
frame the velociraptor model disappeared
they got so lucky it happened then yes
if it would have happened anywhere other
dude it would have been so bad dude
they're so lucky it wasn't the t-rex
though
like
i've gotta re-render this we have two
weeks and it takes two months to render
i would love to find out more
information about why that velociraptor
is missing if you search this up in any
youtube clip it's gonna be there unlike
the starbucks cup which is going to be
gone from forever more from game of
thrones how did that get through
okay so now we're talking about jurassic
world the end of the first jurassic
world movie hd and at a technical level
the effects here are certainly better
than they were in jurassic park so why
do people think that the effects are
worse in jurassic park they these
raptors were real when you see them
walking too they were real so that's
what they're going up against
[Music]
i think growing up this was like the
scariest moment of any movie i'd ever
seen so that's real yeah yes
there's two things that you get with
real one is motion looks a lot more
realistic i can't tell which is because
when you're animating stuff by hand and
cg you can go anywhere the second one is
acting those kids are acting so much
better with real pots and pans falling
on them and real velociraptors sticking
their heads out of things like it's so
much easier to get into space when you
have an actual dinosaur on set versus
like all right look at this man with the
green ball so you want to imagine it's
where my fist is yeah and you guys want
to focus right here it's like
oh it's a dinosaur it's like even if
you're chris pratt
it's still tough to do
if you actually like pause on any of
these frames they all look really good
what's he doing is he trying to be
friends with the dinosaur yes this is
aliens have you not seen it no for so
much of this you can just tell that it's
computer generated regardless of whether
or not it's technically good
and because you can tell that it's fake
you can tell that the people that you're
watching are not actually in any real
danger and your suspension of this
belief is a little shattered yep it's
very interesting
with a with a smaller budget jurassic
park was crunched into choosing their
vfx shots very very wisely and they
didn't hold shots for longer than they
needed to
it was it was real they treated it as if
it was real and it looks more real
because of that exactly whereas this is
they can do whatever they want so
they're going artistic with it and
creative yes but as they go artistic and
creative it's becoming less real correct
remember that remember that moment from
jurassic park three when the
velociraptor was sitting on the airplane
was like hey allen
wait this i thought you guys were
kidding
me this is the real thing i need to see
this
this is good just let this play is the
reference to the twilight zone
i've had that dream before no i gotta
wake up my car and now it's driving alan
[Laughter]
is
yeah
that's so dumb well because someone's
trying to wake him up and he's like hey
alan wake up
didn't even like the mouth like move for
both syllables like hey ellen
you really don't know who i am genie
wishes lamb none of that ringing a bell
that's like that right there
everyone had a problem with that shotgun
one very specific reason because it's
obviously will smith
but everything about it looks wrong he
looks like and no one can exactly tell
why he looks like a minotaur like look
what he's walking he's floating look at
him he looks like a miniature why's he
walking why is he taking steps he's not
walking he's floating but it looks like
he's like hey it's me he's just floating
along we just can't see the bottom half
of him that's because because my brain
puts him as a minotaur like he's a
minotaur right there can you figure out
why it feels wrong red what it comes
down to is that it looks unnatural and
is triggering a very specific part of
our brain that identifies faces and
humans oh like all the check marks are
listed as like that's obviously not just
a person but will smith and it's not
just the fact that he's blue it's his
kind of proportions his face kind of
looks a little too small for that size
of a head his neck looks a little too
thick and i think a lot of that is
mostly driven by the actual camera focal
length and placement and whatnot amazing
cg body there like
hot cg body for the next cg
the muscles on his back like they flex
and they move and they indent they pull
the skin
yeah yeah it's that's incredible
artistry it's great it's amazing and
then for the front his cg body still
looks good
yeah but it's like what happened
there's a face from a man who does not
have that body
kind of like just paste it in the center
it almost feels like the blue doesn't
match and this might be a color grading
thing where they just put a mask here
and brighten his face no it's the cg
face 100 of that face is cg okay but
like his face is actually a little
bright compared to the rest of him it's
like oh we need to be able to see his
face here so i'll just draw a mask here
and brighten it up oh like a power
window yeah like color grading thing
power into this but it's actually
throwing off the lighting now because
his face should be in shadow like his uh
left peck is his face should be about as
bright as that peck in the shadows but
it's a little bit brighter
[Music]
everyone reacted super negatively to
this specific shot myself included but
then they released a follow-up trailer a
few weeks later see this looks great
because it's lit well you're not showing
too much and also if the proportions are
specifically thrown off he looks super
huge so it's triggering our brains a
little bit less than if he was trying to
fool us completely
genie can't trick me the genie can't
trick me
a big thing is the lighting like in that
shot there's a nice like edge light and
there's a clear defined key light it's
giving his face volume and like
character versus the other shot is like
this just ambient wash like a little bit
of light on the side
so they have nothing to really this goes
back to what we were talking about
earlier with the very specific uh
directional lighting yeah like this
that looks really good is this a
lighting issue i think it's a lighting
issue i mean it's a little bit cg monkey
though it looks pretty good it looks
great see he looks fine right there
something i noticed here so his abs
right there's actually a little bit of
discoloration there almost as if it was
body paint and this is actually a tricky
thing of visual effects is a lot of what
we understand about reality in movies is
not actual reality but what we've seen
in special effects so like for example
when people get shot in movies we expect
there to be a pop and dust in blood and
that's not what happens when people
actually get shot when you're doing
visual effects you're not always going
for reality you're going for a simulated
special effect and therefore you'd have
slight discolorations and things like
that you end up making it look more real
because it actually looks like real
makeup as opposed to an actual blue
person
[Music]
terminator 2 a classic the movie that
set the bar for jurassic park and pretty
much all cg in today's modern era yeah
not a wasted minute literally not a
wasted minute oh there it is
dude that's so sick so this is actually
mostly a compositing thing this isn't
this isn't like a computer-generated 3d
model or anything this is straight up
classic after effects type stuff yeah
that one right there
it's pretty incredible honestly in fact
there's a little bit of a vfx history
lesson to give you guys here with this
shot ilm kind of pioneered morphing and
morphing is actually a pretty simple
thing basically you're just doing a
distort and as you're distorting you're
doing a crossfade and after this people
went crazy for morphing it was like
morphing was the hot new thing for a
couple years for visual effects shops
now the reason i bring this up is
because there is a sequence of morphs in
michael jackson's black and white music
video that are the
best morphs i have ever seen in my
entire life and thanks for watching if
you want to see us review any other sort
of movies or tv shows leave a comment
suggesting what we should see next but
in the meantime try clicking that
subscribe button just restocked our
store with some of our most popular
classic designs so those of you who know
what's up you can look good while
hitting that subscribe button this free
returns so it doesn't [ __ ] whatever
send it right back we'll take it